i don't okay well let's even say no
picture but you can write on it
ben loves steven forever and have our
hands
yeah maybe holding
so you've no doubt heard of the
controversy of some states passing laws
to protect religious freedoms
not funny haha funny queer but many of
you probably read about it from places
like this but that is not what's
happening here
see these laws are allowing businesses
to maintain their private right of
refusal to be involved with
certain activities like say baking a gay
wedding cake
which tastes fabulous by the way to
those of you wondering yes you are still
killed in virtually every muslim country
for being gay the media is deliberately
trying to set the narrative of
mean hateful christians versus poor
innocent gay people who are having their
rights completely trampled
yep gays are still hanged in iran let's
say you're a baker and a gay person
walks in and wants a birthday cake
fine no problem happy birthday now if
they want to force
that baker to make an expressly gay
wedding cake
the baker has the right to not be
involved with that particular activity
do not compare this to civil rights no
yeah gays are still killed across the
middle east in record numbers daily
another example if i'm a baker and kanye
west comes in says he wants a wedding
cake to not serve him simply because
he's black
or an idiot would be illegal now if
kanye comes in and says he wants a
wedding cake with his lyrics gold digger
broke
written across the front of it i can say
i'm not quite comfortable
with creating this cake and there's a
shop down the street that might be more
suitable for you
these laws are not about protecting
discrimination against people
but the right of business is to choose
their level of engagement
in a specific activity speaking of
islam's hatred of gay people what do you
think would happen if we went into a
muslim bakery and asked for a gay
wedding cake
no need to wonder we did it for you
what's really important is getting the
picture and the writing so it's going to
be
me and benny well you have pictures
there no
in kroger yeah like the grocery store
no more
uh i wanted to say ben and stephen
forever on the top and then on the
bottom it'll say
um same-sex legal now congratulations
but everyone keeps sending me somewhere
else they said this is what you do here
no i don't want it
i don't okay well let's even say no
picture but you can write on it ben
loves steven forever and have our hands
yeah maybe holding
no but we want at least the writing you
know
so you know groom and groom there's two
grooms
yeah a wedding um
wedding is for um two people getting
married
but just the writing you don't need the
machine that you can do the writing ben
loves steven forever
groom and groom yeah you can do that no
no only all of these places did do
custom wedding cakes that's their
business
it's kind of what they do of course many
of the muslim bakeries were kind enough
and willing to serve us
but many of them were not for christians
it only took
one lawsuit yet the media never
acknowledges the giant
burked elephant in the room
and liberals say you're just
fear-mongering you really think the
rights of christians
would ever be taken away what about when
that's exactly what's happened in places
like canada like this pastor in 2007 who
was found
guilty of hate speech and banned from
public speaking until he had to file an
appeal or the fact that millions of
christians now have to participate in
what they believe
to be murder or how about this situation
where gay men wanted to ban
this chaplain from the navy simply for
his views on marriage
so to be fair chaplain
know your audience by the way i'm not
even saying that these muslim bakeries
shouldn't have the right to do what they
did
they absolutely should and many more of
them
would than christian bakeries that's why
most gay people probably don't go into
muslim bakeries and i felt like they
were going to blow me up when i was
there
and that's the issue roll the clip the
burden placed upon these same-sex
couples is
they go to another vendor and they get
the service they ask for nobody's
ever had a problem why don't the
see when this guy says well then maybe
the photographer shouldn't go into
business it's very important to know
what he's saying it's pivotal
it is absolutely key because what he is
saying
is unless you agree with me and my
worldview 100
i should have the ability to ensure that
you can't do business that you can't
make a living it's the legal version
of the cultural marxism that is
political correctness
you only speak the way we allow you to
speak
or you're not allowed to speak does that
sound like freedom to you
let me know below do you honestly
believe that this is a dialogue of mere
hate versus love or do you think that
religious freedom's come into play at
all
let me know and what of the muslims
because when it comes to gayness they've
made their stance quite clear but
everyone keeps sending me somewhere else
they said this is what you
it if you do this video subscribe by
clicking my face you're watching this
previous video here
it's free and if you don't a gay man is
going to be hunging around not because
you didn't just because that's what they
do